yo yo yo welcome back to the edge with
your boy Michael Parsons live in your
Bleacher Report app we're here in
Orlando at the Pro Bowl and I got some
special guest I got a special guest
joining me later on in the show but
obviously you already know why I'm here
I'm here to speak my
peace and early on um off rip I
disappeared off the map went out to Peru
with my family uh to re-evaluate you
know just life just like everything
passed that loss and if you think I was
okay with that loss or how we lost at
any point shape or form you're obviously
delusional very
delusional um let's just get right into
the loss um obviously Jordan love played
an unbelievable game um but at the end
of the day we were just outperformed out
schemed however you want to put it like
they had an answer for everything and
people saying well why a't you go to
linebacker cuz you know they said you
can stop the run well guess what the
packages are in for me to go to
linebacker there's multiple packages
multiple variations but I can only play
what it's called what whatever they're
calling whoever Personnel they're
putting on I'm not putting out Personnel
I'm not putting out uh the Cs there
nothing's coming from me so you could
put that and put that wherever you want
to be or wherever you want to put it but
they're not coming from me the packages
are in I've even told multiple players
coaches that I'm very fine playing
linebacker and playoffs if that's what
y'all want me to do I just want to win
and you can ask any coach ask any player
that a god honest truth because
obviously this is not where I want to be
sitting right now speaking to you
talking about what we're doing at the
Pro Bowl and that's just the reality of
it I do see a Super Bowl in my future I
want to be a Super Bowl champion and
it's very upsetting that I'm even here
Happ to even speak to y'all and trying
to say if I really care about the game
and if I'm showing up in playoffs I
challenge anyone to actually go look at
the game film and say did Mich play his
heart out in that game and what more
could I have done you know and you know
it's sad man that you lose the way you
do especially at home talking about how
much we played at home uh how much it
stood for us to be at home and to go out
like that at home was completely
embarrassing and unacceptable so you
know I couldn't even look at that loss
or feel any type of way because of how
embarrassed I felt I felt you know the
utmost you know just man it was just I
say it it took me a while to even be
able to show my face in the public I
like disappeared like completely so you
know it it really showed to me that you
know um that you really see how much
people care about the game of football
and the culture and uh the people you
want around you when you say you want to
build a super Bowl championship team and
the the truth about it you know and um
it sucks and you know you know s s here
and uh you know they talking about we're
going all in this year man that's what I
would hope for you know I'm 24 years old
I've been in this league you know three
years and I kind of seen it all and uh I
hope that we go all in I hope that we go
out and get the players that we're
missing because we didn't do that this
year you know I hope that we challenge
ourselves become better and become
greater for us um and I'm trying to say
this in like the most nice way possible
because of how like I truly feel and you
know you got analysts and um you got
guys like skip that just talk so crazy
out on the media just because they can
skip I've never once asked you to Hype
me up or do anything like that you did
that because you saw what I was doing on
the field um like I've never want you to
jump on my coat tail or you're the one
that wanted me on your show to come
speak on your show uh and I wanted to do
my own route because of your bad ties
and who you are I did not want to be
partner with you and that's just point
blank simple so you could drive whatever
narrative or whatever what whatever you
want to be but a person who's been all
pro for three years and however you want
to put it I guess I am not that guy and
I got to do more or to be a guy whatever
narrative that drives your boat or
whatever you want to fit um but go watch
the go watch that Packers Game and Watch
Aaron Jones follow me wherever I went uh
and you could say that they blocked me
but I mean Jordan love had almost every
accessible throw uh there was so how can
you get a quarterback if you as a pass
rusher you look for opportunity for the
quarterback to hold the ball you know it
like it it just is what it is and that's
just the game you know it's tough and
it's very disappointing um and you know
going into this year uh there's just a
lot of work and a lot of culture that
needs to be established for us to be a
Super Bowl team I never believe I
believe that uh you know the Super Bowl
has never won really by the best team
it's by the team that can put it
together so obviously the penalties hurt
us again um penalties hurt I mean look
at the Ravens game I believe the Ravens
was be far the best team
um and they did not go on to win that
game I mean you look at penalties you
look at momentum shifting plays uh it
just it just happens to be that way
experience is a gift um and obviously
surrounded by really good players and
really good
coaching but you know I do see a lot of
people you know
overreacting um I and you know a lot of
blame goes on to Dak Prescott because he
is a quarterback and people look at his
playoff wins but we gave up over 40 plus
points what what do you expect Dak
Prescott to be do you expect him to be
Superman he cannot win games by himself
I've always said football is not a game
of one man it's a game of 22 men that go
on the field and you need to rely on
every 22 guys to win that game it's not
relied on one individual two individuals
it's a team that can play together as a
group the best collectively not give up
big plays and not cost their team uh
first downs and things like that so
I do not put down Dak Prescott he is a
allpro he has played a terrific game um
could or would have should have been an
MVP but he's not and to put that
narrative you know people want to drive
whatever narrative that fits best for
them and that's what I'm realizing about
this game of football and that's what
kind of drives away the happiness
because people don't appreciate how good
someone has been um they want to attack
them for where they're at or what they
have done and things like that um so I
think that came a long way um obviously
one of his better years since I've been
with the Cowboys so that Narrative of we
want a different quarterback or we want
a different guy I think he's been a
great leader uh whatever whatever
however y'all want to put that
um you know and and that just drives me
to I'm at complete peace you know and
and I say that because I don't think
I've could have done anything more to
try to uh win that game and that comes
to watching film with the other guys in
the room saying what I'm seeing being
vocal out there on the field um I was
completely at peace because I know I
don't have no regrets about how I
performed or what I put into the game
and uh you know and I appreciate what
really matters in life and as family uh
outside you know um I don't think that
game defined me at all I don't think you
know that moment uh Define me so I'm
completely at peace of how I went I
can't change uh how I went or you know
where it went so I'm completely at peace
I love where I'm at in life I love my
family and I love from where we're going
and I love how they're talking and how
we're going to look
ahead you know and that means I believe
in Mike McCarthy uh we want a lot of
games with Mike uh 36 wins uh under the
belt with Mike so you know hopefully uh
he could take us all the way and you
know we drive this culture and we change
the narrative that people
have you know but now I'mma bring in uh
my special guest um from the
Philadelphia Eagles DeAndre
Swift Su Swifty on PA dogs in the house
pa pa pa
pa you know y the Swift it's it's your
first Pro Bowl how you feel man I feel
good man I feel good to be out here it's
a blessing I know bro you know I'm even
more happy just CU you know we really
came from the same part seven on seven
together um so you know I'm happy about
your success and what you been able to
accomplish uh you know how did you like
Philly this year what was the difference
between Philly and Detroit because
Detroit had a lot of success this year
um what what you think uh you know
what's the difference between Philly and
Detroit
uh Detroit I speak on Detroit first
Detroit doing their thing right now um I
can kind of tell when they left that
they was going to have success they got
the right people in the building right
coaches but um Philly was a little bit
different um first and foremost the food
was better in the facility food was
better uh culture was a little bit
different um but it was good though it
was good it was different but it was it
was it was good in the same same sense
all the people there from top to bottom
um equipment people everybody in the
building um the way they treat you man
it it was it was it was great it was
great being there this year for sure I
mean I feel like we in the same boat I
feel like we was one of the better teams
in the league that fell short and uh you
know what would you say to concerned
Philly fans that you know may have
concerns about how Y season ended just
knowing we had the team that could go
the whole way and we fell short just the
potential that we had we had the talent
to do it just came up short so that's
what I think the frustration really is
uh 100% I mean I feel like y'all was
similar I feel like you know same way we
had nine all Pros I mean just anything
you can imagine we had and around and we
just couldn't put it together man that
that frustrating fact I don't think
people realize how competitive we is and
how it makes us feel like it's nothing
personal and I don't think the fans
really what would you say to the fans
that really don't understand how
competitive and how frustrating it can
be when you just can't put it together
um and you you trying everything your
possible way too yeah I say don't nobody
want to win more than us as players yeah
they see the product on Sundays and
Thursdays and Mondays but it's a lot of
work that go into it throughout the week
a lot of preparation grind throughout
the week
um but don't nobody want to succeed more
than the people on the field that put
the helmets and shoulder pads on yeah
100% I mean so they got to be
be patient with us as much as they can
yeah you know what what could you
pinpoint like 10 and one number one C
everyone saying y'all y'all going to be
there you know what what what was the
shift like what was the energy like
talking about when after this we started
losing streak right there
uh it's tough it's tough um you know
later in the year people start playing
their best ball later in the year it
come down we ain't make enough plays bro
that's how I feel we ain't making enough
plays people might say play calling
coaching whatever is may be but at the
end of the day we out there we got to
make it happen whatever might get called
players got to execute it com down to
execution so that's what I feel like we
really didn't do a good enough job of
like from top to bottom we just ain't
making enough plays yeah 100% And you
know it's crucial and I keep telling
people don't just live off of one person
or two people it take all 22 like and I
feel like that's where a lot of people
fa to realize they were like man why AR
our best guy you know it take three like
even as P rush it take three other
rushers for that that your your guy to
actually succeed he got the D tackles
got push to pocket the other guy got to
be balance his rush you know um the same
way on o line man you can't get off
unless you know whoever don't pick up
the block or don't Shield them off or
get the kick out so you know I I think a
lot of people expect some guys to be
Superman sometime times and you know and
sometimes there's going to be once in
every 200 plays where you are Superman
where you break five six tackles and uh
but people don't realize man you you you
know you playing the best in the world
and it's that for a reason um free
agency man like where you want to be
back in Philly you want to stay home or
you know would you like to stay home or
would you like to go elsewhere I mean
you one of the best prospects in free
agency um anybody be lucky to have what
you think I mean I know we tired of
playing you you know um so where you
thinking about heading man uh waiting
right now um I feel like we'll see what
happens um time will tell with that uh
just kind of focusing on training and
stuff like that right now cuz I don't
really I don't know what's going on
right now waiting on phone calls and
stuff like that to see what's going on
um but we'll see when it gets there when
the time is right you coming back to
Texas yeah I'm coming back to Texas yeah
you going to be in Dallas or a in Dallas
yeah over there yeah we going you know
I'm stay so you might know when I know
yeah yeah I might be in the building I
might be when I know um let's get in
let's get into to y'all goal line man I
mean are you talking about tou push yeah
like how frustrating is cuz I know you
could you could get an End Zone it
seemed like you kept falling at the one
yard line yeah that's my fault
though that's my fault first game
actually um Vikings game I get down to
the one I look to the sideline I'm
thinking they call another run yeah yeah
no tush push yeah after that I'm like
anytime I fall at the one I knew it's on
me it's on my it's my fault yeah Jason
Kel even said he said I'm sorry man you
know exactly what we about to do like
how how often was that like he had 15
touch like as a quarterback 15
touchdowns is crazy like eventually like
i' be like man like do you talk to
serani or the OC like yo can I get at
the one like one every one every four
times or like is there a conversation to
be had like it ain't no conversation
anytime it's short yard it's CU you know
football it's it's a numbers game so the
percent of the tush push succeeding is
very high so we calling it first and
goal if we on the one if we on the two
we might call him run but on the one
it's over with I seen on the two y'all
went TS push twice we did that was crazy
like we did we did n we we might have to
take it out the game so that way uh
y'all can eat over there man like they
ain't trying to let you run your numbers
up like what it is man I got to score
when I need to score N I feel you I feel
you um
you know what you know since we uh what
what would you say what was your top
five defenses you played this year yeah
seen some good ones
um san fran san fran
um Dallas there's no order there's no
order San Fran Dallas um who else had a
good
defense Seattle was good Seattle played
as good I feel like everybody played
like we got everybody's best n y I feel
like Eagles Cowboys is in that round
where everybody want to beat us like
yeah everybody you everybody getting you
getting their best shot every get their
best shot like it's the Super Bowl for
sure 100% 100% but um so that's three uh
who else Chiefs Chief solid especially
over there at home that's my first time
playing in Kanas City too loud they got
a good defense um give you one more um
the Jets the Jets n the Jets people
really underes the Jets yeah they nice
over there they got a good defense that
was your first loss of the Season too
that was our first loss you know and I
noticed like in getting the discussion
of valuable positions every team um
pretty much every team had a great
linebacker core you know yeah Jets had
two of them yeah two of them yeah they
was they was legit they was legit for
sure um you know man uh who who's your
pick for the Super
Bowl
it's tough it's tough it's tough to go
against Patty it's tough to go against
Patty but um I I like the 49ers I like
the 49ers like I said it's tough to go
this Patty this it's a tossup right now
it can go either way I feel like go
either way who you
like last year I had that same
conversation they was like man who you
got and I was like man um the Eagles was
so much more talented than the Chiefs
but experience and coaching it matter
truly matter matter you know I Haven
said coaching is 70% of football almost
you know 30% cuz I said 30% players you
know if you one on one with they best
guys you might win 50 60% of the time
and and that's just something you got to
live with because you know that's the
match up that's how designed but if you
design to get that one onone with that
particular particular individual you
know that scheme that you know to create
those matchups and things that's how you
create that movement so you know man
it's hard to go with the against the
ners because of how much talent they got
but I'm the same way with you Pat can he
do miraculous things Andy Reed man they
it's crazy yeah and and I think it's
gonna be a fun match up to watch cuz
McDuffy Jer sne against uh they outside
and bbo yeah yeah that's going to be I'm
tuned in for this one yeah this is I
think this is going to be uh and then I
don't know Pat Mahomes he been having a
numberers too oh they playing good ball
right now you seen with Kelsey there
last week like they playing they playing
good ball at the right time yeah I think
that Fred and uh Travis match up is
going to be very interesting for sure
for sure I'll be tapped into that man um
let's take some Pro Bowl questions from
the chat um before we wrap up will we
see you at QB for flag football I ain't
get the rules yet but I'm hoping they uh
switched them up from last year and let
you know defense play offense and
offense play defense especially since
they let Tyreek Hill play middle
linebacker last year um today Advantage
favorite thing about the Pro Bowl
weekend I would say my favorite thing
about Pro Bowl weekend will probably be
things like tonight you know uh you know
rent out uh Universal Studios all the
families get to go uh get the bonding
time with the players uh building
relationships connections things like
that I always think that's like the best
part you know the relationship with the
players because you know the league is
only going to go as far as we go so uh
that's usually and it's usually
hilarious like you talk about all
different type of stories things that
can never say lie things that you notice
so uh that's probably going to be one of
my uh favorite parts of the trip and you
give me I'm going be with my son and uh
all my loved ones so it's going it's
going to be real fun uh Swift what's it
like playing for the Philly dogs it's
cool it's cool I ain't really get the
chance to play with everybody that came
from Georgia um but it's cool being in
the same locker room in the NFL locker
room as you was once in college with you
know what I mean just see how them guys
grow and uh mature from the next level
um it it was cool it was cool to be a
part of it did you feel any added
pressure before the playoff game or did
it feel uh business as usual obviously I
think playoffs is way more intense um
but I didn't feel no pressure I just
felt um I I never really feel pressure
because you know pressure is a a
privilege I really just feel like that
that anxiousness to wanting to win that
that like you really want to move on you
really want to get to that next level so
I wouldn't say uh it's pressure I feel
like I'm just more an like and you know
um you know you always anxious to see
the outcome you know I'm saying you know
win or loss you know it's either going
to be a sad moment or a happy moment
it's no more uh next week as we know so
I think it's more anxious and they
saying you plan on playing in the
Olympics the Olympics yeah the flag
football Olympics yeah if I'm available
if they want me to play I'll get out
there for sure that's what I said I I
mean to get a gold medal yeah to get the
gold medal of course who who's your
dream lineup like who would you play
with like whole line offensively yeah
right
now receiver quarterback just name the
whole thing yeah okay we GNA go AJ AJ
Brown It's Gonna Be biased though you
need three receivers okay I'm going AJ
you can't be biased it's going to be
though I'm telling you it's going to be
AJ um Smitty M
uh put uh give me um give me CD okay
give me CD you want that super speed
Tyreek I feel like you got have Speedy
like do you
do I can't I can't give give me re
instead of CD give me and CD instead of
C I feel like there's no lineup where
I'm not having Tyreek kill you got you
gotta you gotta you got to respect him
like 100% right 100% right quarterback
give me uh give me Jaylen you GNA take
jayen yeah you not taking Pat Mahomes he
in the Super Bowl I don't even know if
he competing Olympics he in the Super
Bowl this is Olympics everybody
everybody jig give me jig over oh
man dang who who's your backup QB there
always two you always got two Patty you
gonna take Patty all right um who who's
your uh lbs you
taking off the ball right you on C off
the ball yeah okay give me um give me
ran ran give me ran and uh give me Fred
okay yeah and uh Edge you got your Edge
go Michael Parsons um me RIT you choose
your all Philly bro no you asking me
that's who I'm picking oh man oh man
that that that was real crazy me Sean re
and Michael Parson's on the edge you
don't like that I mean no I I like I
like it but I'm just saying your lineup
is real biased I told you that
before I told you that yeah I see I Ain
know how biased but
man you know you know if that if it's my
lineup you know my lineup I'm definitely
taking Pat off rip Pat is going to be my
uh starting QB um and then obviously you
know I'm choose my quarterback that he
he's got they got to be my onew punch
okay uh my receivers I'm definitely
going Tyreek he he's going to be my one
um you know cidi he's always going to be
my slot cuz he play outside and inside
like he's Dynamic um and then at at my
ex I got to go with Devonte you know I
got to get you know he his route running
is too impeccable oh we forgot about
tight ends who's your two tight ends
give me
um uh I go Kelsey Kelsey you said two
yeah you get Kel I know I
know um yeah you know tight ends man a
lot of a lot of people stepped up this
year Ferguson had a good year Ferguson
went crazy good year he had a good year
I I I really like to see him get his
expanded role into the offense like you
know they use him in a lot of different
ways Run the game out a lot of checks I
like to see cuz you know towards the end
of the year he was getting way more
vertical they would have BR that um
early in the year I feel like he would
have went for Le Porter numbers or KD
numbers say he had a hell of a year yeah
yeah yeah um but right now obviously you
got to go Kelsey um at tight end and
then the other ones a toss up you know
CU I love KP uh
Kyle um man
but Andrews is a dog too yeah yeah I
think I got to go Kelsey
Andrews um cuz I think Andrew's in the
Red Zone boy
he yeah yeah yeah yeah um and you know
my Edge
guys you know I outside of myself yeah
about say don't pick yourself I'm not
I'm not outside of myself I'mma go with
uh Max and
Miles Maxim miles yeah I Max's effort is
just yeah yeah every play whole game
yeah Max that that's that's that's a dog
good s and Miles you know he's just yeah
um and you know my Corners gotta go with
L
Ramsey um for sure and then for me my
next three corners I'm going for ball
they go to go for the ball so I'm going
deep blend Trayvon oh yeah and uh on the
outside on the outside ah on my other
outside I got who who would I pick
it's a lot of good Corners sne had a
good year sne had a great year but I
feel like that's what I'm getting out of
jayen he long press Corner Physical
corner I I I need somebody like
more yeah what you looking for it it got
to be a dominant nickel it gotta be a
dominant nickel uh what the name from um
jles Bangles
21 you talking about Hill yeah Hill H
and cool but I think uh Jaylen Johnson
went crazy this year oh he play Nigel
from the Bears I didn't Jaylen Johnson
play outside he play didn't he do he
play outside he nice I like him then I
gota go with Kenny somebody like Kenny
or some you need a dominant nickel like
somebody who scrapp you on the inside
you do definitely do yeah yeah but that
that that'll definitely be my lineup um
but you got a couple more questions from
the chat factor is the most important to
you as you enter free agency uh I would
say just the right situation it's the
right situation that's what I would say
when it comes down to it um right
situation for me my family that's about
it if Swift EJ's team play Mike's Pence
te who's I'm not even gonna lie to you
ask I'm not even gonna lie to you you ug
going I mean you know we G to put up a
fight we gonna fight and we GNA try to
win but that ug lineup is uh I mean
y'all got about 20 first round picks for
a reason like glad you kept it 100 yeah
I don't even lie to I don't lie to the
people y y no it got bad I answer for it
got bad now y I mean y'all was blowing
y'all blowing teams out I mean we had a
squad we had a squad I mean seeing what
Jaylen C and Jordan Davis is becoming I
mean qu Walker he's hooping I mean yeah
we doing good over in Green Bay man um
anyone y'all think was SN from the Pro
Bowl I think Antoine Winfield got snub
oh um I mean couple people yeah I I mean
I definitely think there was a quite a
few people who got snub um man but I
think he was like the biggest snub of
them all andine he had a great year
great year turnovers picks yeah you know
I know they try to say it's the voting
but you know players and coaches vote
too we we count for other two3 so I
don't I know he I wasn't in an offensive
room so he wasn't obious my ballot but I
got a you got a question you know what
he had my vote you know and that's
that's where I say a lot of things was
wrong with the players I feel like that
we do is like a lot of times they just
vote for names like we a just we ain't
looking at what people was accomplishing
and doing this they just voting
names like even when you look at her all
pro list like a lot of that was name
based like a lot of people had way
better years than a lot of people so um
I think we need to change that how we
look at the game and vote for the people
who's actually having great more
deserving I mean we see that a lot of
times in Pro Bowl I there's guys who
have 10 plus sacks and make Pro bowls
cuz you know obviously you going to vote
for the legends of the game and things
like that but um we definitely got to do
better right there that's my first one
I'm just glad to be
here yeah yeah I'm happy you here too we
have a good your pops here he get here
uh tomorrow yeah my pops get here
tomorrow you know they about to go crazy
tomorrow um you know last one how's the
eagle and cowbo on the same couch uh you
know at the end of the day man it's all
love me and Swift we've been locked in
since high school uh seven on seven
teams uh recruiting process you know I
thought you was coming to Penn State for
a little bit too I did too for a second
yeah did too and then you you hopped on
the wagon to Georgia but you know he
left the state and I'm going continue to
rep the state and that's all that
matters um yeah what made you to GGA is
it that nil it's too late for them to
get you no I ain't that wasn't that
wasn't even a thing when I was in school
that was that's the only visit I took
but other than Penn State um we drove up
the Georgia um it was just it felt like
but I I wanted to get away from Philly I
wanted to go play sec I know I wanted to
play SEC and um Georgia it was just felt
like home away from home people the
coaches um the way they way they take
care of their players yeah I love
Georgia when I was up there too y'all
had something special going on um it it
was great but you know I I appreciate
y'all tuning in uh to the Lions Den Pro
Bowl show uh we going to have a great
show at the Super Bowl I can't wait for
y to see it tune in it's going to be
spectacular maybe the best show of the
year um so I can't wait we always going
to do bigger and better for Super Bowl
thank you for tuning in thank you for
hearing our piece thank you Deandre
Swift for coming on the show uh we
appreciate y'all and we'll see y'all
next
[Music]
week